>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Robert Newlen: Well,
good afternoon to all,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
My name is Robert Newlen, I
have the pleasure of serving
as the deputy Librarian of Congress
for institutional advancement,
you're sitting in our
magnificent member's room,
a room I think Bob would've
appreciated very much.
It's my pleasure to
welcome you today --
to today's event, announcing
the gift
of the Bob Adelman photo archive
to the Library of Congress,
and honoring the life and work
of this incredible
photographer and artist.
It's wonderful to see so many
familiar faces here this afternoon,
specially the members of
Bob's family, his friends
and fellow artists,
who traveled from all
over the country to
join us here, today.
In particular I want to welcome
Bob's daughter; Samantha Ray,
and his colleague Steven Wadd,
who collaborated with our staff
to help created an event that Bob
would be proud of, our thanks too,
to Helena Zinkham and Erika White
for bringing us all together today.
Today's guess speakers are
befitting an icon like Bob.
You will hear from the Librarian
of Congress, the Poem Laureate,
an award winning New York Times
photographer, a legendary novelist
and short story writer, and a
renowned curator of photography.
After the formal speaking program,
there will be a brief question
and answer section, and we will
conclude with the reception
where you can view some of the
remarkable images from this archive.
I also want to mention that today's
program is being live streamed
on YouTube, and recorded for a
webcast that will be available
on the Library of Congress website.
Before I turn it over
to Doctor Hayden,
I just want to say what good fortune
it was for me to spend some time
with Bob over the past several
years, during one of his visits
to the library, my partner and I had
a small cocktail party at our home
in his honor, at some
point during the evening,
Bob began examining the art
on our walls and he smeared
on a small water color that was
painted by Gloria Vanderbilt,
and this led to the most remarkable,
and I'm guessing undocumented
story about this commission.
Bob said that he rarely
accepted portrait commissions,
but he made an exception for Miss
Vanderbilt, and he did the portrait
at her home at [inaudible] place,
and was really quite an
extraordinary portrait.
The present time prevents me
from recounting the whole story,
so I'll just leave it as a
very, very warm memory of Bob.
And now, it is my pleasure
to welcome the Librarian
of Congress, Doctor Carla Hayden.
[ Applauses ]
>> Carla Hayden: Good
afternoon and it's an honor
and a pleasure for
me to be here today.
I am pleased that the Library
of Congress is now entrusted
with the preservation and eventual
exhibiting of the collection
of the photography
of mister Adelman.
In his own words, "Life's
work is about the many
and the diverse social concerns on
America; poverty, mental illness,
alcoholism, inadequate housing,
the immigrant experience"
and his collection, so
marvelously documented;
the struggle to overcome
racial discrimination,
and like so many other
Americans, I was deeply moved
by the photographs he took on
Birmingham, Alabama in 1963,
when the police in Ingram
Park used fire hoses
to push back African-Americans
who demanded civil rights.
It's especially significant as
I'm the first African-American
to lead the Library of Congress.
As he said, the fire
hoses were brutal.
They ripped the bark from the trees,
and nevertheless the people held
on to one another, and
were able to resist.
The images which I've learned since,
that were used to promote the march
in Washington, made me think
about Doctor King, and the message
that change does not roll in on the
wheels of inevitability but comes
through continuous struggle.
And I was personally struck by
his own message that photography,
and his photography was not only
quote, "Intend on telling the truth,
but doing something about
it" and in his own words,
it was a constant effort, not only
to document what he was seeing,
but to figure out how
to change things.
Change, as we know, is a continuous
struggle and demands constant effort
and [inaudible] which is why, the
Library of Congress is so proud
to preserve his work and
collection for future generations,
and thanks to the generosity
of an anonymous donor,
the library has acquired over
600,000 prints, negatives, slides,
and other materials documenting
not only the African-American civil
rights movement, but the many
changes in American culture brought
about by remarkable
individuals like him.
Sadly, he passed away last March,
and I was not able to meet him.
But I have heard many
stories from staff members,
in particular Mister Newlen,
who left out a little something,
if you get him at the reception,
he might tell you the true glory
of Vanderbilt story that he
has actually meant him to.
He was a graduate of Berkley
University, at Columbia --
the university -- he taught at the
new school for social research,
and the School of Visual
Arts, Stanford University,
Ohio State University, and
the University of Minnesota.
He also worked with the
International Center for Photography
in New York, and the Museum
of Fine Arts in Massachusetts.
His photography has been published
by Times magazine, Harpers magazine,
the New York Times magazine, as
well as Life, People, and Squire.
He also authored, edited, and
illustrated over a dozen books,
including Martin Luther King as
celebration, award and image,
Remembering Jack on President John
F. Kennedy, and Out of Left Field,
[inaudible] and the
Pittsburgh Pirates.
And additionally, his photography
was included in the book,
"This Light of Ours;
Activist Photographers
of the Civil Rights Movement".
He was awarded a Guggenheim
Fellowship,
and multiple art directors'
clubs honors.
He went to University of Missouri
School of Journalism of War,
and his work was included
on the American Institute
of Graphic Arts, "50
Most Notable Books".
And now, we are honored that
his collection will be preserved
and exhibited by the prints
and photographs division
of the Library of Congress.
And if it helps, a deputy Librarian,
Robert Newlen, it is now an honor
to present the Library of
Congress's latest acquisition,
and in case you were wondering,
to really unveil what's
under this cloth.
[ Applauses ]
>> Helena Zinkham: Good afternoon
everyone, I'm Helena Zinkham,
Chief of the Prints and
Photograph Division,
delighted at such a large turn
out today, and I'm your moderator,
so you'll see me coming
up and down frequently.
Juan Felipe Herrera, the Poem
Laureate, has written a special poem
in honor of Bob Adelman, please --
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you
so much, it's an honor to be here
and I want to thank the family --
the Adelman family, for this moment
that you have provided
to me, and everyone.
Such a beautiful experience to
see, to notice the photographs,
and I was very moved when I
looked at the various books
that Bob put together, and his
photographs, it was something
that made my life, when I was
a child as immigrant -- some --
my mother had us a small brownie,
and it made her life most
interesting and creative,
and it gave us all something
that we can still look at,
and we turn to, and continue with.
This is called -- this is partial,
a partial American alphabet,
a photo bomb, for Bob Adelman.
Listen in Danny; run, stop, meditate
inside a cardboard box somewhere
in Brooklyn for a day.
Bob Adelman follows and they
play, they hide in the premises,
splash themselves on the concrete,
hugging me [inaudible] with a kite,
I'm bigger that the Empire State
Building, Danny says, smile angelic,
"I don't want to be on your
teen visit, B is for black,
W is for white, I is for
-- I'm sorry I said that,
J is for jealous, I
am just a bum player.
W is for when we are
together, it is all right.
Bricks and brambles, concrete in
a lone gray, and white and white,
and black and water, and time;
that's something that splits us
in half, it's something that puts us
back into one, this is we're singing
for the Congress of Racial Equality,
S is for Student Non-Violent
Coordinating Committee,
J is for Jim Crow; no Crow, no
more, and Adelman is less, we see,
we notice, we enter, we
move, we are the people,
even though we are far
away, inside the camera,
break away, break through".
Adelman says, "breakthrough",
Adelman says,
"breakthrough for a moment,
a half moment is enough
to start getting free, if is
for [inaudible] in Mississippi,
O is for others, there's [inaudible]
in Alabama, and B is for B.B King,
and Memphis and C is for
Cooking, and calking your hair
to make it smooth in
the white world.
Listen young man, [inaudible]
and the Black Arts movement;
make a revolution with words, with
spoken colors, with heart that comes
at you with a voice, in a lens.
Don't cover up your
lens", says Adelman.
"Don't you cover up your lens",
says Bob Adelman, "open it up,
until there's just breath,
into breath, into our breath,
so you can breathe into freedom,
so you can breathe into freedom.
M is for [inaudible] with an
umbrella, as a storm ahead
of him unravels, T is
for took and cotton,
and Alabama, can you see it America?
You got one minute
to lie in the cotton.
New machines, new screws,
move the matter.
M is for machines, and
sometimes it is for madness.
L is for lit stain, make sure every
dot of your face is in the picture,
make sure your eye [inaudible]
encounters pierced into you.
M is for marching into Montgomery.
T is for tenant farmers and
its socialites; socialites?
Time for reflections in the
lens, after you give your life
in the fields you vanish, but not in
Adelman's black and white exposures.
There's a proud woman in
its Pittway, has wallpapers
and a wood burning stove, and
Martin Luther King on her mind.
Yes sir, yes sir, Q is for quills,
and basket makers making changes,
read, by read, needle
by needle, inspiration.
J is for [inaudible] blowers, and
H is for horse [inaudible] writers,
oh yes, this is not as
simple as you think.
There's a way through, to freedom,
yes indeed, yes sir, yes madam.
There's a way through to freedom.
Baptisms in the water, and
James Brown all around,
N is for white not
singing in Alabama.
A is for America, I'm not leaving,
I'm not going back to Jim Crow.
F is for fire hose spray, and kill
it, Ingram Park see it peel the bark
of the trees, while you
hold on to each other,
while you hold on an
Adelman's camera.
A is for Adelman as he holds you,
as he holds onto you, into you,
as you hold onto him and if stops,
but 550,000 exposures that hidden,
not on page [inaudible],
not silent, not invisible.
A is for America, A is for Adelman;
put the alphabet together,
put freedom together.
Everybody say freedom --
>> Freedom.
>> Everybody say Adelman --
>> Adelman.
>> Everybody say freedom again --
>> Freedom.
>> Not silent, not invisible.
Put freedom together, S is for
segregation, separation between you
and yourself, I is for
innocent while arrested,
T is for three generations
of tenant farmers,
and S is for school integration
until you get too close.
But you have to, you
have to get close.
Everyone say, you have
to get close --
>> You have to get close.
>> You have to get close --
>> And that's what
the camera is for --
>> That's what the camera is for.
>> That's what the lens is for.
>> And that's why we get respect --
>> That's why we get respect.
>> Three generations
of tenant farmers,
you get too close, but you have to.
You have to get close,
C is for colored only.
Remember the puzzle?
Texas, 1961; in road to
Mexico City with my Tia Lela,
and my Mother Lucha, which restroom?
Where's brown?
Brown is black, black as brown.
R is for Rosa Park sitting on a bus,
in the bus, that giving up for seat.
W is for we show not be
moved, everyone say, W --
>> W.
>> Is for we --
>> Is for we.
>> Shall not --
>> Shall not.
>> Shall not be moved --
>> Shall not be moved.
>> And Adelman's camera is for --
lay down, lay down in front
the tractor, L is for lie down,
lie down in front the tractor, so
you can stop unfair labor practices
at the Downstate Medical Center.
Adelman keeps moving,
Adelman keeps America moving
in front of your eyes.
H is for holding hands in times
of trouble, like Mimi Feingold
at segregation -- congregation in
West Feliciana Parish, at Louisiana.
Oh, everyone say, oh --
>> Oh.
>> Oh --
>> Is for out of so much
pain, reality and truth,
and compassion, and change come.
Marching, everyone say marching --
>> Marching.
>> Come singing --
>> Come singing.
>> Come [inaudible].
>> Come resisting --
>> Come resisting.
>> Come talking --
>> Come talking.
>> Come saying --
>> Come saying.
>> Come speaking --
>> Come speaking.
>> Come on up --
>> Come on up.
>> To the front free,
with your gut fiddle,
and march until race
beating disappears.
Can you see it in the camera?
M is for memorial services, for
Doctor Martin Luther King Junior,
M is for memorial services
for Malcolm X,
L is for LGBTQ parades,
no more gay bashing.
No more gay bashing.
V is for Vietnam War that you can
pray and touch, and consider all
of those that gave their
lives for you, America.
W is for women's liberation,
say it as Lillie explodes.
Everybody say women's liberation --
>> Women liberation.
>> Everyone say, W is
for women's liberation --
>> W is for women's liberation.
>> Say it, as a Lillie explodes,
and C is for civil rights,
L is for let my civil rights go.
C is for camera; Adelman's
camera, with an S, for see.
And a C for compassion
action, and an L for love,
and a Y for yes, it is possible.
And an E, and an E for is the engine
that moves us together, with Danny,
and Vincent, walking
down the concrete world,
and W for what are you going to do?
What are you going to do?
Because you are in this picture,
because S is for saying grace
at dinner, in Sumter,
South Carolina.
And Z is for Zen, monk,
meditating in Rochester, New York.
And H is for humanity;
Adelman's humanity, our humanity,
our humanity it spells America.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> That was remarkable, thank you.
And as you visit the photographs,
or the books later this afternoon,
I think you will see the whole
alphabet coming to life visually.
We have three other
speakers this afternoon,
I'll ask if you could come up in
the stage, and each take a chair.
Beginning perhaps with James Estrin,
there's some steps
on the other side.
I'm going to take care of all the
introductions in one fell swoop,
and then we can settle
in to hear the talks.
So, James Estrin is a photographer
for himself, who began working
at the New York Times in
the 1980s, he also found it;
the New York Times photography
blog, which is called The Lens.
So, many echoes are going
to go back and forth
with your poem this afternoon.
In 2014 -- actually, earlier,
but then in 2014 you
interviewed Bob Adelman at length,
and that's been published, this is
the blog post, and it was called,
"Photographs that make
a difference".
So, James is going to talk with
us about Bob's career and work,
in relation to American
social justice
and documentary photography overall.
Verna Curtis, who -- she'll
speak second, retired last year
as a wonderful curator of
photography at the Prints
and Photography's Division here,
at the Library of Congress.
She found much common
ground with Bob Adelman,
not only through the
exhibition march in Washington,
co-curator with Marisha
Badle [phonetic],
but also through home town
territory in Miami Beach, Florida.
With more than 30 years of
experience in the fields of both art
and documentary photography, Verna
is ideal to help us dive deeper
into Bob's images, and show how well
they fit with some other collections
at the Library of Congress.
Our final speaker is Ann Beattie,
author of novels and short stories;
I've read that she's been
referred to as a pal of Bob's.
We'll make that more formal,
along standing and good friend.
Sure as a philosophy,
and long conversations.
And Anne is here today as
one of Bob's close friends.
She reportedly rejected Bob's
request to photograph the people
in places in her own
stories, but has written
about his amazing work
with love and affection.
James, you're up.
>> James Estrin: When I
was asked -- excuse me.
When I was asked to speak about
Bob Adelman, my first thought was,
"I didn't really know him that
well" I've met him a few times,
and I've interviewed him twice,
but upon reflection I
realized I did know him well,
but that was mainly
through his photographs.
His images affected me as a young
child looking at them in the pages
of Life and Look magazines.
They affected me as a young
photographer, finding my own path
in the field, and they continued
to affect me today as a testament
to what can happen when people
stand up against injustice.
Bob's photos were always
honest, compassionate.
As a photographer, he worries hard
on its sleeve, and always forth
on the side of the angels.
As a photo journalist,
I've always my images
to affect the situations I
document, but as I got older
and images became more ubiquitous
with the digital revolution,
I've come to believe that
there are few situations
where a photo makes a
difference that is measurable.
Louis Hynes photos of young
children at work changed labor laws.
Perhaps Nick Ootes Napalm
Girl, and Eddie Adams photos
of the Saigon Execution,
helped galvanize opposition
to the Vietnam War.
I've made a few photos in my career
that drew attention,
but measurable change?
Not so much.
We, photo journalists, risk
our lives covering war,
famine and injustice, yet
there's still as much war,
famine and injustice
as when we start.
So, I've come to the
conclusion that for me,
it is enough if I document
those terrible things,
and people see them, at
least they can not say
that they didn't know
what was happening.
And I'm OK with that.
Most older photographers
I've interviewed
for the Lens blog be
known the lack of effect
that their photos have had.
Don McCullin, whose images
of war and famine were seen
around the world, suddenly
said to me flat out,
that he feels that
he wasted his life.
But when I spoke to
Bob Adelman, he said,
"Of course photos change things."
He noted that Garry Winogrand,
the street photographer
once famously said
that photographs don't
change things.
Bob, who was in his 80s at the time,
told me that that was, and I quote,
"The silliest thing he had ever
heard" Bob's photos and those
of his fellow's civil rights -- OK.
OK. Bob's photos and those
of his fellow's civil rights
photographers clearly did help end
the Jim Crow statues; they
help change those laws
by exposing the hideous
nature of racial segregation,
and turning American
opinion against it.
He told Jet magazine in
2014, in a profound sentence,
"The movement realized
how segregation was ugly,
and un-American.
The photographs were the evidence."
Bob's images were born out
of optimism, and the belief
that the American people,
when confronted with the scope
of racial injustices, would
support the movement's goals.
It's an optimism that
Bob continued to display
in his latter work, in
communities in need.
Bob was not just a documentarian
of the civil rights movement,
he was a passionate participant.
He was a volunteer for CORE,
the Congress of Racial Equality,
and SNICK [phonetic], the Student
non-Violent Coordinating Committee,
he was not an outsider; he won
the trust of movement leaders,
and that gave him some
kind of access,
that resulted in knowing the
insider view of the movement.
His intimate images were
instrumental in putting the message
of equal rights for all,
forward at the time.
Today they're useful for
understanding the complexities
of what made the movement tick,
and how leaders presented
themselves publically.
Helena Zinkham has
tasked me with trying
to describe Bob Adelman's
importance in the photography world.
Of course, he documented a
critical period of American history
in a comprehensive manner.
But I think what really sets
him apart, it's the respect
that Bob had for its subjects.
There were other white photographers
who made important contributions
to the documentation of
the civil rights movement,
but too many of them --
though, perhaps well meaning
portray their subject as symbols
of oppression, not as
fully rounded human beings.
Some photographers fantasized
the black Americans they were
photographing, where others
focused mainly on images of violence
and black bodies being violated.
But in Bob's images,
the people involved
in the civil rights movement,
were treated with respect,
and portrayed in the
most dignified manner,
whether they were famous leaders
or foot soldiers in the struggle,
he approached everyone
with equal respect
and this approach followed him
throughout his lustrous career.
This is what I noticed in
his images when I studied him
as a young photographer, and this
is what influenced me profoundly.
Like Bob, I strived to encounter
all people on the same level,
whether they were the most
rich and most powerful person,
or the poorest and most vulnerable.
Encounter everyone on
your level as equals,
that's what I learned
from Bob's work.
Bob made the critically
important historic photos
of the reverend Martin
Luther King Junior,
giving his I have a dream
speech, at the Lincoln memorial,
not far from where
we sit here today.
Doctor King knew Bob, and
was comfortable with him.
Where most of the press was
stuck in a far away pin,
Bob was able to get a close up
photo, because everyone knew him,
and everyone trusted him.
Bob had a master's degree
from Columbia in Philosophy.
I once asked him to tell
me something I didn't know
about Doctor King, since Bob had
several opportunities to spend time
with him, and apparently between
jokes, they discussed philosophy.
Bob told me, and I quote,
"He was a personalist
in his religious vocation, he
believed that everyone was an aspect
of god, and that when we spoke to
them, they deserved the attention
and concern as if you were
directly talking to god."
While Bob was much, much less
certain of the existence of god
than Doctor King, as he
approached the people
that he photographed
echoed that sentiment.
Look at the photo of Reverend
Joseph Cornell standing sentinel
on its front porch, holding a rifle
against the possible
Ku Klux Klan ambush,
after he became the
first black resident
of West Feliciana [phonetic] Parish,
in Louisiana to register
a vote in six decades.
Bob was also their
leader, when a multitude
of shots were fired
trough the house.
This was just one of many times
when Bob encountered violence
and gun shots during the
struggle for civil rights.
He told me, "I realize that my
involvement would be very dangerous,
but I had a long think with myself,
and decided that this was something
worth risking your life for."
In my last interview with him,
he told me that he had
found workable answers
in his philosophy studies,
before turning to photography;
I asked him what those answers
were, because if he knew the meaning
of life, I wanted to know it.
He said that in the sense of
the Middle Ages, he didn't think
that there was an equate focus to
life, or that this world was a drama
of salvation, preparing us for
the next life, he didn't think
that there was any over
arching purpose to life,
but that we were given meaning
through families, experiences,
affections we have and values
that we care deeply about.
He said that funding projects
would be meaningful in connection
with those values, and that would
be as much purpose as he could find.
And I quote, "For me, if I've
gotten involved in something,
it had to mean something, I
had to see some purpose to it,
and that would be something
I care about."
So, Bob studied philosophy,
primarily to find his way
in the world, but it
was through photography
that he discovered the meaning
that he was searching for.
He said, "I realize that I wanted
to get involved in the world,
to make a difference" and he has.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Verna Curtis: Thank you,
Helena, and all of the library staff
for their support, for
the Adelman acquisition
and for organizing this lovely
and significant occasion,
I think it's appropriate to really
look at Bob's career visually.
So, that's what I will
bring to you this afternoon.
In fact, you may be seeing
his images in many places,
and not even be aware of it.
Are we going here?
Don't see it here.
Oops. This is a poster from Raoul
Peck recent academy award nominated
film, about writer James
Baldwin, "I'm not a negro."
Baldwin's penetrating eyes
comes from one of Bob's photos.
Bob got to know him during
the civil rights movement,
and photographed him
during the run of his play,
"Blues for Mister Charlie" If
you haven't seen Peck's film,
it is in fact likely author's
eyes, it delves into the essence
of the man, and does this
in a very creative way.
Peck uncovered an unpublished
manuscript of Baldwin's
and uses those words to
quote his life and times,
offering an unusual authenticity.
The quality of authenticity
also distinguishes Bob's work,
and makes it so very appropriate
for the library's photographic
collections.
Bob came to the attention of the
library staff about 10 years ago,
when he arrived to examine,
potentially for a photo
book project,
negatives made by Ralph Ellison.
Ellison's archive is in
the manuscripts division,
and his relatively unknown
photographic work resides
in the prints and photograph's
division.
My colleague, Marisha Badle, met
Bob and subsequently visited him
to acquire a selection of
civil rights photographs.
And one of them was this iconic
image we've been looking at,
Doctor King.
We organized the photographic
exhibition commemorating the 50th
anniversary of the march on
Washington, in August, 2013.
And the following January
held this symposium with some
of the photographers who
had witnessed the march.
Bob was one of the stars and
spoke, and subsequently was invited
to give several lectures
about his work at the library.
He was asked in effect, to
take on a role of photographer
in the residence, in
the hope that some day,
such a position might
officially be designated.
Here is an energized Bob, during
his civil rights work in the 1960s.
In the movement, he found that
cause that Jim just mentioned.
He saw others give their lives, and
he felt he die for the same cause.
He spoke to the cameraman, one of
these photographs ran on the cover
of News Week, and a participant
at the Seldom March
in the spring of 1965.
You've already seen his most famous
photograph in Birmingham Spring,
1963, and he was there
and he witnessed how the
students wouldn't run away,
holding on to each
other for their lives.
Bob's teacher, Alexey Brodovitch
claimed this image; quote,
"Seared itself into his memory".
Bob did not have much formal
training in photography;
his real introduction
was through his father,
who was a serious amateur
with a dark room at home.
Bob attended Manhattan's [inaudible]
in high school, and then [inaudible]
for a master's degree at
Columbia, he majored in Philosophy,
as we've heard, focusing
on aesthetics,
and continued studying about art.
He spent a year at
law school at Harvard,
but returned to New York City,
and began talking his way
into photographer studios.
Eventually, in 1959 he enrolled
in [inaudible] famous
design laboratory,
at the new school for
social research.
For an assignment, to
shoot in Times Square,
Bob settled on something different;
he took a graphical look down,
on a group of sailors
from the hotel Astor.
For the assignment,
to photograph an egg,
Bob researched whatever [inaudible]
had done with the subject,
and then tried everything.
Persevering until he
could find something
that would be uniquely his own.
This image of a crumbled
hard cooked egg.
Bob believed that besides
qualities of design, his activities
on photography needed
to have purpose,
and the purpose he found was
to fight for equal rights,
support justice, and
help make change
in peoples lives, for the better.
He first got involved
with the Brooklyn Congress
of Racial Equality, and became
their national photographer.
Brooklyn was where CORE
began the freedom rights.
As you can see, people here --
they were picketing for education,
as well as a livable community
and economic opportunity;
themes that Bob would
later expand upon.
Through the civil rights movement,
Bob met many great people; Baldwin,
the political thinker Michael
Harrington, but he was close --
closeness he felt to Doctor
and Reverend Martin
Luther King Junior was
such that Bob always
referred to him as Doc.
He attended King's funeral in
1968 and took intimate photographs
of the family, which
have a permanent
in the National King
Historic site in Atlanta.
Bob's magazine work began in
the 1960s, often dove tailed
with his civil rights photography,
which concerned voter drives
in the south, as on the
left of the man registering
in Sumter, South Carolina.
For Albany, he followed the Reverend
Joe Carter, the first black man
to register and vote in West
of Louisiana, and in fact,
I think he told you James that this
was the most dangerous situation he
had ever faced.
Bob was awarded a Guggenheim
foundation grant in 1964,
and here are two examples of
that work; his proposal was
to quote continuous work
on the efforts of Negroes
to achieve equality in America,
and to begin the study of poverty
in the context of contemporary
affluence.
His application was supported
by Edward [inaudible],
who loaded the valuable project,
and Bob as a serious thinker.
His teacher, Brodovitch, pointed
to Bob's integrity and courage,
and the vitality, and
necessity of the project.
Dorothy Norman, [inaudible] future
biographer concurred, that Bob was,
quote, "Dedicated and selfless,
a person of integrity,
and shows promise.
It's one of the most
effective photographers
of the American social
scene" end quote.
On assignment, Bob was unafraid and
a charmer, with a gift for repartee.
His editorial worked for
numerous magazines, included --
we've already heard, Look, Live,
New York Times magazine,
too many to say.
The assignments were very
varied, and these are from a story
about the daily life of
Sumter, South Carolina Sheriff,
Jay [inaudible] Bornell [phonetic].
Bob documented this drug raid
in New York, it was for Look.
He met and photographed many people,
such as Sidney Poitier, B.B King,
Miles Davis, Tina Turner.
One of the crowds he most
enjoyed hanging out with,
were the pop artists;
James Rosenquist, Roy --
[inaudible], Andy Warhol and others.
Being represented by art
gallery dealer Leo Costelli.
For a magazine article,
Bob cleverly decided
to take Andy Warhol
grocery shopping.
[Inaudible] became a close
friend, Bob's love for art comes
through here, in this portrait in
which the artist stays in position
as the sculpture base,
bellow his own representation
of Brancusi's 1910 Sleeping Views.
Bob was a prolific producer
of more than 60 books,
as well as many bookazines
[phonetic],
continuing after he moved
from New York to Miami Beach.
Some were his own, others were
with and for other people.
This collage gives you
an idea of the range
of these many book projects.
Some unusual, as in the lower right,
even body as [inaudible] of bibles
on the lower right, the book
about the right bold underground
comics, as a form of fog art.
Bob, and the influential cartoonist
and Editor Art Spiegelman
worked on it together.
Next to that book cover, is this
project about the Bill of Rights,
with the head of the American civil
liberty's union Aaron Glazer who's
here today, called,
Visions of Liberty.
Never far from Bob's mind
was concerned for equality,
and education, and about
poverty, which eluded people
from those American values.
Here's an example of the
graphically art full lay out,
that characterizes
Bob's book projects.
An assignment looking at children
growing up without their fathers,
led in the 1970 to a serious of
small books for, and about children.
Some elevating a play,
and many finding a way
to improve reading skills.
Down Home, photographed from
1956 to 1970 and published
in 1971 was Bob's major
first book project,
it is a sociologically study of
people living in Candem, Alabama.
Bob continued photographing the
same people for over 30 years.
He intended to publish Home again,
but it became an unfinished
projects.
Two of the young folks Bob met in
1956 are shown on the book pages
on the left, and on the right
is how he found those two girls,
ten years later.
Bob was looking for
positive results,
from the kind of civil right
actions he had participated in.
In general, he was a
keen observer of process.
There would be more of
this kind of photography.
The better man of America
was Bob's focus.
The next America, in 1974
was a project Bob did
with Michael Herrington,
whom he had met
through his earlier work with CORE.
Harrington had written the other
America, which had had an impact
on the Kennedy administration,
this time he and Bob would update
that book with the decline
and rise of the United States.
Bob was always showing America
how he saw it, and then attempting
to do something about making
life in America better.
He was putting his photographs
to use for social causes,
how the other half still lived was
a petition to President Carter,
to pay attention to the South
Bronx, done under the auspices
of the Philps [inaudible]
Foundation.
The library borrowed a rare
copy of these photographs,
for its recent exhibition,
highlighting the mock
breaking journalism
of Jacob Breeze [phonetic].
Brezze's [Inaudible] original how
the other half [inaudible] gave
voice to the New York City
ten amends, of the 1880s.
You can see that Bob was all
about America, here's a glance
at the great American past time.
Bob's study of the
Pittsburgh [inaudible],
as was during this season, following
the death of Roberto Clemente,
who was killed in a
plane crash in 1972.
It featured their all star player,
and left fielder Willie
Stargell, during the 1973 season.
As you can see, Bob got
into the game himself.
Bob's own involvement in
things is most clearly seen
in the diet, which examined obesity.
He produced photographs on
this subject for Esquire
and for the London Sunday
Times on 1979 to 80.
He took on, on an experimental
diet himself, he exercised,
and under doctor's care
lost 100 pounds in a year.
Bob relished the outcome, and
was never more proud of anything
than this [inaudible] group of
photographs he made of himself.
As you can see, Bob
liked to observe process.
He followed how artist worked,
with close friend Roy Lichtenstein;
he was on set, as the artist applied
color, outline and dot matrixes
for a mural size view,
of an iconic Oval office.
Bob delighted in watching
the artist work.
Carver County, produced in 1990
is a unique visual biography
of the short story
writer Raymond Carver.
Carver's letters and
poems provided the texts,
and Bob's photographs helped
us match those gritty words,
with images of the
bleak, blue colored towns
of the author's native
Pacific North West.
I'd say that Visions of
Liberty, from the early 1990s,
summarizes what Bob stood for.
And the body of photographs
he left us.
Native American children in
the south west or women's march
on New York City, a protestor
at an anti-Vietnam War rally,
a family supporting gay rights.
One of Bob's most popular
images, is this one,
taken at the People's wall, at the
IBM at the world's fair in Queens
in 1964, it is been
interpreted as a statement
about race and class in America.
Actually, this image revels
-- or reveals, I should say --
Bob's delight in technology
and humanity.
He has manipulated his camera, so
as to flatten the ceiling for a ride
that actually was on an incline.
The people appear wary, or excited
as they're about to be sucked
up into an ovoid multi-screen
theater, designed by Charles Eames,
in order to view a film about
design in the technological age.
Bob's career epitomizes what Ralph
Ellison said about his work, quote,
"It moves into the rear sneer,
where in technical ability
and social vision combined
to create a work of art."
His archive now joins
forces with the Library
of Congress's great collections,
which preserves the contributions
to our society, of Ellison, leaders
of the civil rights movement,
and the designers Charles
and Ray Eames,
among so many other
American creators.
His work will continue
to have a place
in American history alongside
his heroes, and ours.
We can just imagine that the
ever smiling, serious, wild,
devilish Bob would be joyful now.
[ Applause ]
>> Ann Beattie: Those were
really wonderful talks,
I've been sitting here
so lost that I forgot
that I have to get [inaudible].
Yes. Bob, well, Bob and I met in
New York City, I believe in 1981,
I was living there with my dog,
and I didn't know about Bob's work,
but I certainly did know his images.
And when I got to know Bob, I got
to know his work very well indeed,
but he came to photograph
me for a cover of a magazine
that folded over the weekend.
So, it was a wonderful cover shot,
I can still see it, with that,
I could've brought it today, but
that's something I've lost track of.
But, that's really how we
got to be friends, and then,
after New York City, when our
lives went different places,
we were just never out of touch, we
did still sometimes work together.
When I first met Bob, we
worked together a bit more,
because he was always kind enough
to have me be the, you know,
the sudden famed epiphany, "I
know who should do this assignment
with me, the writer should be --
long pause, and then he got so the
editor would fill it in, and say,
"Write Ann" yes, "Send Ann again"
but then, I married my husband,
and my husband sort of got --
began the unofficial driver
for all of these adventures.
Bob was the photographer,
I was the writer.
One of the things that really
interested me about Bob, was that --
yes, I'm a writer, and you
can't be that, I think,
without having a somewhat
visual sense of the world,
even if your tools are words, but
if Bob and I did the same thing
of an evening, if it was just
the most ordinary kind of thing,
just going to a dinner and
getting a bite to eat or something.
I would sometimes say to
him, "Wow, did you see that?
That sort of broke chair
that was up there, you know,
above the wing's coding
[phonetic]" and he'd say, "Yes,
yes" and I'd say, "Oh"
because it was right --
over your back shoulder,
and he'd say, "Yes, yes.
I saw it when I walked
in, and it was another one
on the bottom right" -- OK.
Then he'd say to me, "Did
you hear that discussion
about the people who
were breaking up?"
and I'd say, "No" and then, he would
narrate all of that for me too.
So, you know, it does
make sense in a way,
because he was very butch known,
and very hugely talented, obviously,
as a documentary photographer.
But, his interest was on
watching things in lapse of time,
and if you where with
him personally,
this is nearly anecdotal, but,
you know, you would get to know --
no response, I mean, it
was almost like, you know,
he was holding the cards close to
the vest, because he didn't want
to say anything that might in
some way, take away from it
as a potential image, or as what
it was to him, and you can --
writers know this too, you
can talk something away.
I mean, that's the way we
talk about it sometimes.
So, a writer doesn't necessarily
like to paraphrase their work,
because you fell like,
"Well, is that all I wrote
or I'm just giving the
highlights of that plot?"
but he was in name with the maze,
certainly he was -- as we, now --
I'm just curious to know, how many
of you in the audience in one way
or another professionally,
or personally --
how many people here
actually knew Bob?
Oh, like -- lots of
people, yes, yes.
OK. Well, it is a big group, but
that -- that's very interesting.
I think the thing that, you
know, I would say to someone
who didn't know Bob, though, was
abundantly clear in the work anyway,
but still maybe should
be remarked upon,
and that is how really
hard he worked.
I mean, if my husband
and I were visiting Bob,
I got up to the bathroom
at 4:00 at the morning,
the computer screen was glowing,
he was sending something somewhere,
and he was before us at the
morning, and after us at night.
And that was just around the house
that was just keeping up with a lot
of the work that he had to do with
his wonderful assistant, but --
You know, the sheer vigor,
and the amount of energy
that Bob spent was
absolutely amazing.
Because he certainly could've
rested on his laurels at some point,
he could've said, "Please, come to
my studio for me to make a portrait
of you, Doctor King"
no kidding, I mean,
it wouldn't mean how famous
you were, that is what a lot
of photographers do, and perhaps
do well, and get what they want
out of those things, but
Bob always wanted chance
to be the thing that intervened.
And that's not so likely to happen
if you're set up in your studio,
I mean, somewhat, but certainly not
like being in Birmingham, come on --
that's just a very different matter.
But I think, it was always
that reflexive me that Bob had
to be surprised, whether
for the better or for worse,
it really got him like out
of the streets so many times,
when he wasn't just doing the things
that we all have to do to follow
through on, you know, the things
that we've gotten in the scene,
or registered in our
minds at the moment.
So, he was really among many
hard-working people I've known,
surely we all have.
He was really one of
the most hard-working,
and always with such
a sense of generosity
and sincerity about him too.
He of course had his own cosmos,
and we talked to each other
in short end, or we just went like
that to the other, because we were
so sick of the other's different
opinions, or whatever we did.
But if you heard about
Samantha, it didn't need
to be said that, "My
daughter Samantha".
If you've heard about John, there
was only one John in the universe
that was Baldwin's guard.
If you've heard about Ira, you knew
perfectly well it was [inaudible].
I mean, these people were always
on the back of Bob's mind though,
and I think that is a thing that's
true of artist -- visual artist --
artist in any medium is that, you
know, they really want to think
of themselves too, as bolstered by
and contextualized by their peers,
or their betters -- see, it
felt to that broader edge.
And so, you know, that was an
important thing for Bob, to --
I do want to say, though,
that I seemed to me,
I don't know if this will ring
a bell or not with those of you
who knew him, but it
took me a long time
to just realize there's a simple
truth about Bob, which is,
that he was one of those guys that
would always keep you waiting,
he could wear 10 wrist
watches and, you know,
a stopwatch around his neck -- he
was always late, he never could get
out of the house in time.
I mean maybe he didn't get out
of the house the whole day,
when you were waiting
at the front door.
But it took me a long
time to realize that.
Professionally, he was up
for anything, you know,
OK a meteor is coming
down in the middle
of this protest march,
what do I photograph?
You know? He absolutely wanted
that, he wanted that intrusion
of the real world in a lot of
ways, but personally speaking,
I think the way he tried to keep a
handle on things, maybe, you know,
maybe very stern kind
of grip that he had,
was that he would not be
made to conform to the clock,
he would not be made to get going,
even if he might miss
what he needed to get to.
He hated transitions.
I just realized that, very recently,
that he would do almost anything,
including, look [phonetic] bad,
get yelled at because he simply
didn't want to tolerate transitions,
and I don't just say that
anecdotally, I say it in terms of,
you know, the things that we all do,
that maybe we're not so aware of,
or that maybe not quite as easy
to discern is that about Bob,
but we all have these things that
we do to give us a little handle
on the world, and to feel like,
yes, things are always complicated,
but we have to take -- we have
to watch ourselves, we have to,
you know, we have to be mindful.
And he was all of those
things in his work,
when he got there you
couldn't pry him out, either.
But to get Bob out of the front
door, if you've heard that Airlock
that I did, here's to
you, and it's really --
he was really well
leagued with that.
The other thing that I
do want to say, though,
that I think transcends
being just an anecdote,
because I was thinking,
"What will I say?
I did spend so much time with him
in so many different circumstances"
but, one time I was the writer,
and Bob the photographer of course,
and we went out to photograph --
you all know the famous
painting, the American Gothic,
Grant Wood's painting, and
we went to Eldon, Iowa.
I can even remember though,
obviously, 100th anniversary
of being painted, or
something like that,
but it was some impressive occasion.
And Life was documenting this, and
we went out there, and Bob decided
that what would be very amusing
would be to have the real house
in the background, and then,
a photograph of the house
and he needed somebody to hold this
photograph of the house for him.
Well, not at street level, that
wasn't what he wanted at all.
He wanted it from up high,
but we were in Eldon, Iowa.
About as flat as this floor, and so,
no problem whatsoever, so Bob says,
"Come on" and climbs up on the
rental car, huge rental car,
with this tripod, all these
cameras and everything,
and he's standing there in the
middle of the car, and I said,
"Come up there" -- "Yes" -- You
know, I reached just down, "OK.
Great." So, I'm standing up there,
on top of the car, and you know,
he's got me holding a photograph
he's already taken of the house,
like this, and holding with my hand.
And he says, "Could you put your
fingers, you know, more" So,
I'm really kind of holding it,
really out as much in the margins
as I possibly can, I suddenly hear
-- Bob has gone down about this much
on the car, you know, him
and the tripod, you know,
not that he ever comes
up from behind.
And he just goes like
this, and I say, "Bob, Bob,
I'm standing up there too."
OK, that's not my anecdote, that's
just another day of work with Bob.
However, it turned out that I was
leaving Iowa two days before Bob
was, and he said, "OK, so, you know,
the Life crew can give me a ride
to the airport, but you just
return the rental car, OK?"
And I said, "Well, Bob,
what am I going to say?"
And he said, "It's a rental car,
you know, you just -- this is --
it's a rental car, you just do your
best" and I said, "Well, but I mean,
just wait and give me my license is
here" I drive the car in, and the --
and he said, "Oh no, they're
not even going to notice, who --
they don't look, you know,
they look at the odometer,
they look at if you leave
anything in the trunk, you know?"
and he had such a -- he was
-- he could be so convincing,
and sometimes I really wanted to
believe it, did believe it, so I --
drove the car in, people looked as
the car is coming in to the lot.
It's like -- the car comes into
the lot, the roof is like this,
he says, "What happened?"
and I said, "What happened
with what?"
[ Laughter ]
And he said, "The roof?"
and I went -- I said, "I don't know"
and he said, "Want to take a guess?"
and I said, "A meteor?"
I did.
[ Laughter ]
And then, of course that all turned
out all right, at least for me,
because Bob would just say, "Oh,
it's, you know, it's working for,
you know, the magazine, they
understand you have these sort
of setbacks on assignment, and
you just do the best you can" So,
he was really an artist,
he was not just
out there [inaudible] believe me, he
was really doing the best he could
and we've seen such
absolutely amazing things today.
I just -- to leave you with one
very brief quote, because Bob was
so modest that if anyone
complimented or anything like that,
he would never hear about it, but in
the famous photograph of Birmingham
with the fire hose -- with
the fire hydrants opened,
and the hoses strained on
the people, and so forth.
What Bob said about that day was,
"There was as much water behind
the cameras, as there was in front
of it" and you know, it's
just an amazing photograph,
and he hung in there
too, to get that.
They weren't letting him just
stand here, like they didn't see
that he was there, you know?
Very brave person as well.
So, he did, he got that
wonderful photograph, and then,
which I didn't know
until fairly recently,
he printed it up fairly
quickly and gave it
to Doctor Martin Luther King, and
he said, about that photograph,
"I'm startled that had so much pains
and beauty came" So, when you say,
you know, does it do any social
good, does it not overall?
I'm sure from time to time, if
not constantly, tortured by that,
and what we're doing, you don't have
to be an artist to
be tortured by that.
Well, what I do, you
know, really mattered,
but I think it was
certain comments like that,
that were tremendously encouraging
to Bob, and really just write
on as far as I'm concerned.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.